Since the earliest days of humanity, when
we first crawled out of the primordial sludge
and evolved into the bipedal form that we’ve
had for thousands of years, there has always
been violent conflict.
It’s an inevitability, a sad fact of human
life, that wherever we go, no matter where
in the world we spread to, as long as there
are people, there is the risk of conflict
breaking out.
Sometimes it’s small, you get into an argument
with a total stranger, usually over something
mundane like a parking space or cutting in
line at the supermarket.
At the time, the things you’re fighting
over seem important, you have a personal stake
in it.
Other times you’re just having a bad day
and need to get things out of your system.
But conflict has a way of escalating, there
is usually always a bigger fight happening
somewhere out there.
A verbal debate or profanity-laden argument
seems like nothing when compared to trading
fists, being locked in a physical exchange
of anger and aggression with another person.
Then there are fights between groups, gangs
from different places meeting in the dark
to attack each other with weapons, knives,
bats, pipes, chains, anything they can find.
Keep taking that scale of conflict higher
and higher and eventually, you’ll hit the
big one: War.
Conflict on a national, international, or
even a global scale; there is always a war
going on somewhere.
Like we said, humans have always had an inevitable
capacity for conflict, since the first cavemen
fought amongst themselves with clubs and rocks.
But what if, for all that time, over those
countless centuries of our existence, there
had been something else there too.
Something ancient, older than humanity, that
has been preying on our natural capacity for
conflict since prehistoric times.
A Demon Born of War, known nowadays as SCP-4715.
Here to answer that big question: “War!
What is it good for?” once and for all,
though we can’t promise you’ll enjoy the
answer.
It’s hard to pin down exactly what kind
of creature SCP-4715 is.
While it does possess teeth consistent with
the dental structure of carnivores, and a
skull resembling that of a large feline, like
a lion or a tiger, it definitely isn’t a
lost breed or subspecies of cat.
Genetic analysis of SCP-4715 is, more often
than not, wildly inconsistent, with DNA traces
matching many different forms of wildlife
found in the modern animal kingdom.
However, there are also genetic matches to
mammals alive long before the dawn of mankind,
dating all the way back to the Miocene and
Pleistocene eras of prehistory, including
the giant sloth, marsupials, and cave lions,
and a creature called a hyaenodon.
It even shares trace amounts of DNA with certain
other anomalous animals that the Foundation
has previously encountered.
So, this thing is like a big hybrid, a mixture
of all sorts of different species and wildlife,
combining together to form…well, what?
Robust in frame and standing at a minimum
of just over five meters tall, SCP-4715 is
a highly aggressive beast, sporting huge forelimbs
ending with seven digits and each with a semi-retractable
claw contained within.
The Demon Born of War also possesses a longer,
secondary pair of limbs, multi-jointed with
three heavy claws at the ends.
Walking on its hind legs, the creature is
steadied by a huge, muscular tail that acts
as an anchor, helping SCP-4715 maintain balance
much like the third leg of a tripod.
While SCP-4715 does have a nasty, rather antisocial
tendency to attack any form of human life
it comes into contact with, we aren’t just
talking about a mindless beast here.
It seems to solely gun for human beings, showing
little to no interest in hunting any other
forms of flora and fauna, meanwhile in the
wild, other animals instinctively know to
keep away from the creature.
SCP-4715 does display some discernible level
of intelligence, roughly akin to that possessed
by the average chimpanzee.
It is even smart enough to fashion tools and
weapons out of available materials.
The creature is also highly intuitive, able
to accurately sense the emotional and mental
states of any sapient life nearby.
But this is where it gets even stranger.
Remember when we mentioned that oh-so-human
capacity for conflict and even war?
Well, in the event SCP-4715 senses any person
with the intention to do harm to another person,
animal, or to SCP-4715, the creature will
rapidly start to grow.
Normally, the amount that SCP-4715 increases
its own bodily mass is directly proportional
to both the number of harm-intending persons
around it and the intensity of their dangerous
feelings.
For example, put SCP-4715 next to someone
who just wants to throw hands for the sake
of it, it wouldn’t get all that bigger.
But if you were to say, surround it with a
group of warmongering politicians, then it’s
a safe bet that you’d see some rather different
results.
The biggest SCP-4715 is known to grow is around
twenty four meters tall, although it has the
potential to grow much, much bigger if exposed
to enough situations of conflict.
However, the moment that SCP-4715 loses its
sense of harmful feelings in those nearby,
then this effect will begin to reverse itself.
That doesn’t mean SCP-4715 enjoys getting
smaller again, in fact, the creature has been
witnessed attempting to draw individuals into
states of conflict to once again increase
its mass.
The Demon Born of War is a very apt and accurate
nickname for the creature, as it seems to
be fascinated by and attracted towards any
state of conflict between human beings.
In addition to its aggression and size-altering
abilities, SCP-4715 also displays exceptional
speed and strength, as well as being resistant
to most forms of damage.
Conventional weaponry does little to cause
lasting physical trauma, its skin is almost
entirely fireproof, the creature has a natural
resistance to toxins, radiation, or other
harmful chemicals, and it doesn’t even require
nutrition in order to survive.
Even on the off chance that something does
happen to cause damage to SCP-4715, the creature
is more than capable of regenerating and regrowing
its own tissue, even to the extent that a
lost limb will grow back within a week.
Given humanity’s extensive history of conflicts,
on both a large and small scale, it is no
surprise that SCP-4715 has been able to sustain
itself since prehistoric times, or so it is
believed.
While its true origin predates some of the
earliest human civilizations, the SCP Foundation
first learned of the creature’s existence
in October of 1916.
Following this initial discovery, the Foundation
has since uncovered a whole catalog of various
artifacts and documents from all over the
world that seem to confirm that SCP-4715 has
existed in its present form throughout the
majority of human history.
In May of 1980, the Foundation located a Roman
structure found buried deep underneath Istanbul.
Within were a series of frescoes, an older
form of mural painting.
The first of these depicted the soldiers of
the Roman Empire battling against the forces
of the Sasanian, otherwise known as the Late
Persian Empire.
The second of these unearthed frescoes showed,
standing in the midst of these two mighty
armies, was none other than SCP-4715, attacking
both Romans and Persians alike, showing no
mercy to either side.
And in the final fresco, Roman soldiers were
shown trying to appease the Demon Born of
War with offerings of meat, the earliest known
depiction of religious worship focused around
SCP-4715.
Additionally, the Foundation themselves enact
a similar ritual offering and sacrifice in
order to keep SCP-4715 contained, known as
‘Procedure 4715-Waning Moon’.
Every full moon of each month, one member
of D-Class personnel must act as a shaman,
cover themselves in human blood and offer
the creature sixty kilograms of red meat.
After feeding, SCP-4715 will sometimes also
eat the shaman too.
But those Roman frescoes were far from the
only ancient artworks depicting SCP-4715,
nor are they the earliest form of representation
that the Foundation has discovered.
A collection of cave paintings was also found
in the Ardèche region of France in October
2005, portraying further instances of SCP-4715
attacking early humans, surrounded by skulls,
and depicted alongside other foreboding, symbolic
imagery.
A wood carving dating all the way back to
Prussia in the mid-14th Century showed more
scenes of the same sort.
In this one, sixteen knights mounted on horseback
were engaged in a cavalry charge towards SCP-4715,
which looked to be significantly bigger than
it had been portrayed in other artifacts,
thanks to the creature’s size-altering abilities.
An engraving on this wood carving reads “Banishing
of the beast from the earth”, and curiously
it was sent to the SCP Foundation in 1981
via a courier with the following note included:
“Dear Sir or Madam, knowledge is power,
and we have observed your organization gathering
resources in order to learn more about the
subject of this carving.
Given your modus-operandi, we believe that
in providing this historic artifact, free
of charge, you may be able to successfully
‘contain’ this creature and put a stop
to its disruptive activities.
Yours Sincerely, Nigel Tissington-Evers, Marshall,
Carter and Dark, LLP.”
Fourthly, an archaeological dig uncovered
a journal that was promptly confiscated by
the Foundation.
This journal had belonged to a Chinese farmer,
made homeless by the Taiping rebellion between
1850 and 1864.
The man witnessed and sketched in his journal,
a monster emerging from a large pile of corpses
left discarded on a battlefield.
The being, or SCP-4715 as we know it, then
started heading towards the city of Nanjing.
Needless to say, SCP-4715 has gotten itself
around over the centuries.
Drawn out to anywhere that conflict is occurring,
the Demon Born of War doesn’t seem to have
much compunction over being witnessed by humans.
But a highly important question still remains,
where on Earth did SCP-4715 actually come
from?
This beast has stood in the midst of human
civilization since we first learned to walk,
feeding on perhaps every conflict our species
has ever had.
But surely, it must have started somewhere?
A nest, a hive maybe?
Or perhaps a dark, unassuming corner of the
world that few people have ever set foot in.
The Foundation has learned of a Location of
Interest designated under the name ‘LoI
517 Sigma’.
In 2009, a group of outdoor enthusiasts stumbled
upon a place unlike any they had ever seen,
describing it as “some kind of shiny bunker
or Egyptian Colosseum in some caves lit up
by shiny plants.”
The SCP Foundation stepped in to investigate
these findings, discovering a cave system
and a structure contained within a network
of tunnels.
Strangely, parts of these caverns seemed to
be organic, similar to SCP-2932; Also known
as Titania’s Prison,
this anomaly is an ancient temple formed of
plants, designed for use as a prison that
can contain its inmates in pods.
This cave system, LoI 517 Sigma, appears to
be of a similar design and function, however,
it is instead focused solely on the containment
of SCP-4715.
Much of the organic devices found within LoI
517 Sigma are still alive and show little
signs of damage, however, they remain inactive,
powered down while the Demon Born of War is
held elsewhere by the Foundation.
Deep in the very heart of the complex network
of caves and tunnels lies a structure formed
of an indestructible plant; a cell that once
housed SCP-4715 itself.
So, who trapped SCP-4715 in this place?
And how did it ever escape without leaving
behind any traces of damage?
Well, throughout the complex of LoI 517 Sigma
are places that seem to have once been inhabited,
residential areas for whoever the creature’s
mysterious jailors were.
And there are even more images of SCP-4715,
once again showing it locked in battle, but
not with humans this time.
In these drawings, the monster is fighting
unknown entities and seems to be much, much
larger than the Foundation first thought possible.
There are remnants within LoI 517 Sigma, of
carvings and warnings, that describe “A
demon born of blood and war”, a bloody night
where children and Fae were seemingly slaughtered
indiscriminately by an abomination born out
of atrocity.
SCP-4715 killed thousands of those that imprisoned
it, and perhaps even created it in the first
place.
But someone set it free.
Within the cave complex, a skeleton lies next
to an organic mechanism believed to have controlled
the power for the monster’s prison.
The skeleton belonged to an instance of SCP-1000,
a species of ape more commonly known as Bigfoot.
In its final message, this ape described mankind
above turning their weapons against each other.
“They know not of the demon born from war,
and cast aside any tool that could turn aside
its fury…
May the hairless usurpers suffer at its hands,
and pay for their transgression.
To any Child of the Night who finds my message,
know that I have committed this crime to avenge
our demise.
You will not forgive me.”
And with that, seeking vengeance for a dead
race, SCP-4715 was unleashed to prey on the
conflicts of humankind.
Now go check out “SCP-1984 - Dead Hand”
and “SCP-186 - To End All Wars” for more
frightening wartime SCPs!